[Music]
good afternoon everybody my name is
Karen Botti I'm with Google and I lead
the scientific computing efforts for
Google cloud thank you for coming and
the title of the talk this session is
scientific computing with Google cloud
platform experiences from the trenches
in particle physics and earth sciences
you know for computational scientists
this is a really exciting time you have
the they have the ability to really
leverage almost infinite set of
resources they have the ability to to
access new processors new accelerators
and of course new software tools and
platforms to really take all that power
and put it at the fingertips of
researchers with with Google's global
network and 17 regions distributed
around the world it's no wonder that
many of the largest scientific projects
are coming to are looking to leverage
the Google cloud infrastructure for
their operations as they scale we've
been working with a number of the
different scientific computing projects
including the CERN Atlas team as they
build their infrastructure to enable
their scientists to make the next set of
of scientific breakthroughs today we
have Mario lassic Passyunk from CERN is
the Atlas Data Manager he'll be here
talking about some of the efforts that
that that they have in integrating the
Google cloud infrastructure and services
into their existing data and compute
systems
but Google cloud is not just for the
largest projects in an effort to make it
accessible to all scientific projects a
few years ago we made a partnership with
the National Science Foundation and
provided three million dollars in cloud
credits for exceptional research
proposals in the area of big data the
proposals were reviewed in the same
process that National Science Foundation
has and those that were funded were had
access to Google cloud credits that they
could then a significant amount of
credits that they could use for enabling
theirs their science one of those
projects that was funded by this program
was the Pangaea project this was a
collaboration between Columbia
University the National Center for
Atmospheric Research in anaconda the
company that provides a lot of
scientific Python tools the Pangaea
project the focus of that is to build a
science platform for earth scientists to
to essentially do their science while
underneath have all the cloud
capabilities with kubernetes with Google
Cloud storage and the other services
today we have dr. Matthew Rocklin from
anaconda here to show that platform and
and to explain how they're leveraging
Google Cloud 4 in order to build it I
should also point out that Google
provides a fairly robust set of services
on in the free tier so by signing up for
with Google cloud you get $300 worth of
credit in addition to the the core
capabilities within the free tier of the
services in addition to that for
academic researchers if you need more
resources than the free tier provides we
have a research credits program where
where we will provide additional credits
for the scientific community
they're building and developing their
scientific applications so please join
me in welcoming dr. Matthew Rocklin from
anaconda to talk about the Pangaea
project thank you
so hi everyone my name is Matthew
Rocklin I work for anaconda
so anaconda is a for-profit company
behind lot of the open-source Python
stack
however today I'm also representing a
broader collaboration than includes auto
scientists and infrastructural
institutions originally Columbia and car
but now sort of a dozen other
organizations so they're real yeah so
our goal in this collaboration this
particular collaboration is to help many
scientists analyze large earth science
data sets cheaply and we're going to
dive into those few words in a moment so
to give a quick example this is so this
is a video of the Earth's oceans this
video of a simulation of the Earth's
oceans this was created on a
supercomputer in some institution in
Colorado and it is actually quite scaled
down you can see a lot of interesting
detail here ok those sort of tendrils
come in off of Japan there you can see
you know tithes everywhere there's any
sort of enclosed area this is scaled
down this actually is about a 2
petabytes simulation in total and this
kind of data is what oceanographers help
to to understand help them understand
how the oceans work which in turns helps
us understand things like erosion also
things like how heat moves throughout
the earth which drastically affects
things like our climate
so whoops
so we simulate our planet like how we
saw in a video we also observe it with
things like satellites in the sky or
land-based assistance this is critical
for many fields like oceanography also
climate science those things are more
immediately pragmatic things like
weather prediction will there be a
hurricane in the next week on the Gulf
or other systems like agriculture or
insurance is gonna be a drought next
year how that affect crops how them
affect regional instability in northern
Africa however once we have those large
datasets I'm back here for moment once
we have these large datasets these are
you know petabytes each for the
simulations nASA has missions that
launch you know somewhere between one
and tens of petabytes per year coming in
to satellite imagery every once we have
those datasets we now need to analyze
them typically this is done by querying
some large data center pulling off a
small bit of data to your local laptop
and then using natural Python tools like
numpy pandas and scikit-learn
interactively with jupiter notebooks
this is the workflow that we were really
focused on we're focused on the
analytics side of these large earth
science data sets there's some
challenges here the first is that the
datasets are different from what normal
big data tools are used to their large
gridded data sets
imagine the temperature and pressure and
wind speed everywhere on the earth and
many different altitudes over time that
data set doesn't fit into a database
that's sort of differently structured
than what you normally find most bi
tooling
it's very very natural to use in tools
like numpy pandas or x-ray which are
very designed for these sort of gridded
data structures well those tools have
traditionally not scaled well this was
sort of a mismatch we either have scale
big data tools designed for tabular data
sets or we have more scientific tools
that are designed for lost small amounts
of data so one solution we used to solve
that problem this is what I particularly
work on is a tool called task which is a
library for parallel computing on Python
and tasks imbues other Python libraries
like numpy are like pandas Purdue
scalable variants of those libraries
allows you to scale up the Python
ecosystem to 100 terabytes scale for
late naturally we'll see an example of
that in a moment
the other challenge we face is increased
access so some people have access to
these supercomputers some people have
access to these data centers but
relatively few you can imagine there
might be a graduate student in the
Philippines with fairly low resources
both in terms of global connectivity he
can't download the petabytes from
Colorado he also may not have the
financial resources to buy all the
credits on that and so we need to create
services that allow them to run their
combinations remotely bringing the users
to the data this is a problem that many
organizations face we also face it and
we're going to solve that problem with
Jupiter hub so go may be familiar with
people maybe people may be familiar with
Jupiter and Jupiter hub allows an
administrator to easily provide Jupiter
instances to many people within an
organization we're gonna see example
that as well so I'm gonna show an
example here of Pangea org if you want
to you can go to this website now pan
geo data org this is a Jupiter hub
deployment running on Google cloud
platform you can sign it with github
credentials and when you sign in you
have the option to create a server we
provide you a your own personal Jupiter
notebook server
let's get forward a little bit as we
wait here Google cloud platform is
actually spinning up for us some node
somewhere on the cloud that will take a
little bit and we're dropped here into a
Jupiter lab session so Jupiter lab is
sort of the next generation of the
Jupiter notebook it has the normal
notebook interface on the right that you
seen it also has things like a file
browser you can open up a terminal you
have a full Linux workstation here and
you can do things like manager
environment with pip install libraries
cond install libraries and this is very
very nice on a personal machine I use it
daily but becomes very very valuable
when you're on some remote system no the
manage that system and keep that
persistent so a combination of Jupiter
lab and Jupiter hub we found is a really
good tool to give a variety of people
access to remote system and again you
can do this now let's go to pen
yup I doubt it work so here let's do a
little bit of science we're in this
notebook and we're going to import some
libraries like numpy and x-ray and we're
gonna look at some data stored on Google
Cloud storage or look at the sea surface
the sea surface height of a simulation
over time we can see here we've opened
up the data with x-ray x-ray is sort of
a mix of numpy and pandas together a
bunch of different variables with this
variable the sea level altitude which is
sizable it's not huge and it's chunked
up into various blocks on Google hot
storage so that data set is too large to
work with on a single machine machine so
we're gonna use desk and kubernetes to
give us more computational power we're
gonna ask for I think 40 workers and
then again we're using a Google cloud
platform to rapidly scale this users
environment to include many many more
machines on that same cluster they're
gonna have to connect to that I'm going
to open up some data so we're gonna open
up this data set and look at just one
day of it so this is showing us the sea
level altitude over time over the over
the globe at fairly fine resolution and
so what you can see here it's a little
washed out here unfortunately what you
can see here is let's see this is the
earth and you might go see the
continents on the Left there's Africa
and they're sort of the some Wiggles
coming off of Africa and that's the red
and the blue or difference is an
altitude of the oceans so you can see
areas where the ocean might be higher
might be lower we live in a low-lying
area like the Netherlands or the
Philippines you might be very concerned
about about that altitude that data sets
around 70 gigabytes it's not huge but we
can sort of bear that we want to work
with them with a laptop we're gonna do a
few computations with that data we're
going to aggregate over spatial
dimensions reduce the time average
aggregate over just a longitude so we
have both time and latitude and then
average average over the spatial to roll
all the social hours in this is giving
time
forward to the competition we're going
to open up the task dashboard so we get
a sense of that computation of what's
happening so this is telling us the
activity of our cluster as we're running
with so again desk is gonna give us the
ability to scale standard numpy and
pandas like workloads onto many machines
in a cluster here we're defining some of
those workloads with the x-ray library
which is useful for our geosciences and
now we're computing that so the busy
plot on the right shows the activity of
all of the cores of our cluster every
horizontal line corresponds to the
activity of one core and over time you
can see they're working on different
things so one color like the green might
correspond to loading data from Google
Cloud Storage another color like the
light green might correspond to
computing some aggregation red is
communication between nodes and so we've
we've done is we've broken down this
large computation into many thousands of
small numpy computations and then Dass
and kubernetes are working through all
of those competitions for us and when
that gives us that gives us now we've
computed these three different data sets
or a look at the aggregations it's all
throw throw out first where to expand to
full screen so we've got the full image
and here so we've taken all the spatial
dimensions and we're now just looking at
time and we see two different things one
we can see some oscillation seasonally
those are the earth breeze a little bit
with the oceans we also see a sort of a
standard upward trend so sea level is
rising and what's really nice here when
I pause this just for a moment what's
really nice here is that we didn't
actually need to rely on an agency or
trust any organization to give us this
analysis all the raw data was available
to us on the cloud it's publicly
available and we were able to with our
our own computations go to that data set
and do that analysis on our own this
sort of removes any sense of politics
from the conversation of whether or not
sea levels might be rising
so it really democratizes a lot of the
ability of anyone on the globe currently
to analyze these worth of data sense if
we take that same analysis and throw in
latitude
the slow part here is actually rendering
the image not the computation so we
throw in latitude we can see how sea
level rise will change over time on the
x-axis but also how it varies over
latitude you can see for example there's
a sort of a strong difference here at
sort of 37 degrees latitude there's a
strong difference which is actually
coincidentally right where we are so the
sea level rise variation increases quite
a bit that latitude and here's variation
over time so you can see on sort of the
eastern coasts of a lot of land masses
there's a lot of increased variability
you can see a lot of increase in
decrease of the sea level rise over time
so again these are just some examples of
how you can today right now if you sort
of ignore the rest of the talk you can
either run this analysis on your own
with open datasets living on Google
cloud with a computation on Google cloud
this whole computation costs us
something like 50 cents so this workflow
is scalable but it's also very very
familiar so if you're familiar with the
Python ecosystem the tools like numpy
and pandas an X array and Jupiter are
very familiar to you and because of that
this architecture has been redeployed in
many different environments this has had
great success this combination of
scaling with Jupiter and scaling with
tasks the rest of the computational
ecosystem has been wildly successful
especially as scientific communities so
this is very commonly deployed on HPC
systems for example in institutions like
NASA while the national national center
for research whether you came at office
where they just played Jupiter hub and
tasks on HPC job scheduler and they run
that on some sort of data center this is
great these institutions already exist
it's a little bit challenging though
because they all have their own
different data sets and that siloing of
data sets can be quite challenging when
you have to move large data sets around
fortunately the same exact stack also
works on the cloud with tools like
kubernetes and it works on any cloud
platform that supports communities like
Google cloud platform and what's nice
here is that because many assertions are
all placing their datasets on the cloud
suddenly all these competitions become
much more universally available you can
mix and matching you can combine your
your oceanographic data sets
with your population movement data sense
that and there it's all publicly
available so it's very pleasant to start
combining those things so just briefly
some successes and some challenges we've
run into so this has been really started
as a collaboration between a science
group at Columbia data infrastructure
group at the National Center for mush
research and some open source offer
developers in anaconda but it's rapidly
spread out to other groups so many
government organizations and also many
different other scientific domains what
I showed up above was used for
geosciences but it's equally applicable
to genomics or do imaging lists munities
have reached out but also applicable to
many more for-profit enterprises so
numpy and pandas are used in geosciences
and everywhere else as well
scale so scientists are regularly
interacting with hundred terabyte data
sets I would say interact I don't mean
computing on hunter by data sets
I mean they've opened up a Juber
notebook and they're typing out that
notebook and they hit hit enter and they
expect to get a response back within a
minute or so so they're actually doing
interactive analysis with these these
large complex data sets sort of human
time scales that's really important for
the innovation of science and we're also
doing science so the people at Columbia
who were designed to do this work are
doing this work and they're coming up
with new you know new analyses in the
cloud in particular has been very nice
because auto-scaling has been very
helpful to reduce costs without
maintenance we really don't pay anybody
to manage the system that you can play
with now it's up there it's live it
breaks very infrequently and it's
usually my fault and it's relatively
cheap these analysis are because we can
scale our closures up and down we can
burst out to a thousand machines and we
can go back down again to zero again and
we can we can be very fairly cheap in
that way this is also been pretty
impressive for access so if you sort of
watch people who log in a lot of our
graduate students lot of undergraduates
all of them aren't in resource rich
countries and it's been very exciting to
see this large scale analysis be be
taken out to those those other
communities
however those a lot of challenges so
we're struggling with interactivity on
sort of petabyte scale data sense so
task is sort of underlying parallelism
machinery seems to be struggling to
operate interactive time skills of those
sizes data formats so the established
formats for gridded data things like
hdf5 don't work very well on cloud
storage there are alternatives but now
we have to sort of build consensus among
a lot of scientific communities to
establish new common data formats
designed for infrequent random access
there's a general lack of expertise
among the science IT community there's a
ton of people who are designed who are
well trained to handle HPC clusters and
there's relatively few people in the
science community who have sort of the
cloud native skill set that's some
retraining process needs to be done and
then finally there's resource management
so you know things like Jupiter Humber
kubernetes lack some of the fine-grained
user management around software
environments resource limits data
sharing and governance that are sort of
tricky if you want to manage you a
thousand users all hammering a cluster
with their own particular resource
queues is I actually so taking up my
open-source happening on my enterprise
hat your anaconda Enterprise solve these
with their problems and actually didn't
understand what these problems were
before I built a system like this it was
sort of hard to understand all the pain
that goes around stopping the users from
breaking the cluster before you have a
bunch of users actively trying to break
a cluster so ok so that's it from my pit
I'm gonna hand it off tomorrow in a
moment but give it a try let's go to
Pangaea org you can play with that exact
same analysis it should all just work if
you want to learn more you got a pan
geodata org if you're an interesting
partner if you want to join in there's
many organizations that come and play
with us ideals to get involved so we're
a community organization we do all for
common communication on github pen geo
data slash pen geo so thank you so much
yeah works okay hello everyone my name
is malleolus Nick I'm with the European
Organization for Nuclear Research
commonly known as CERN thank you Karen
for giving me the possibility to speak
here to you and I do this on behalf of
the Atlas collaboration so Atlas is one
of the experiments that we host at CERN
okay maybe I should stand here okay so
just a little introduction CERN is a
particle physics research lab at the
border of Switzerland and France
beautiful Lake Geneva and our
accelerator complex is 100 meters
underground you have the Large Hadron
Collider the LHC 27 kilometers
circumference and you have four
experiments for detectors attached to
the LHC and we basically make particle
beams collide in the center of these
detectors and our experiment is the
Atlas one so this is what an example
event looks like so there's a
cross-section of the detector it's
layered like an onion different types of
things that we can measure most
importantly the energy deposits over
time of the decaying particles so what
we get with the yellow dots that you see
are essentially hits in the detector so
you can imagine this is a camera and it
takes pictures every 25 nanoseconds so
that's a lot of data coming out of there
if I'm not mistaken it's roughly 1.7
petabytes per second and then we trigger
that down in hardware to event sizes of
two to eight megabytes in size so this
is just the raw data coming from the
detector but computing at CERN has a
quite longer history than that on the
left-hand side you can see the original
machine that Tim berners-lee used to
create the original technology for the
world wide web it's now in our museum it
actually still works they hadn't
invented too
years ago when they tried it out again
then we improved a bit so our data
center right now is I believe at 250,000
course that we provide 300 petabytes of
disk and 200 petabyte of tape yes we
still use tape but eventually all of
this is just the infrastructure
underneath what we actually want is
plots like that on the right hand side
this is what the people are actually
interested in and if you're a particle
physicist you can see the Higgs boson in
there you might have to zoom in a bit
okay so how do we do the computing for
the experiment we leverage what we call
the WL CG the worldwide LHC computing
grid now CERN is not the only sense of
providing capabilities we have a hundred
and seventy data centers all over the
world for 40 countries all together
800,000 course some discs some tape and
the aggregate network that we can use is
roughly 3 terabytes it's all it's a tier
structure so we have T 0 which is CERN
and then the large data centers Pro cave
in National Laboratory Rutherford
Appleton Laboratory all those kinds of
very big approaches are involved and
then we have two tier 2 s and T 3 s
those are universities and laboratories
within the National Research Council's
funding agencies that are attached to
the logit it's really a tiered structure
and what we do is heterogeneous
computing so our data centers are
publicly funded so it's not like
somebody in Spain makes a decision to
buy Intel processors and then everybody
in the world has to buy exactly the same
harbor no every single data center have
their own funding structure their own
decision making process so it's really
everybody can do what they want
literally and we have to make sure
within the framework of the wshe to make
it work together and not only that the
data centers not only support the Atlas
experiment but also many different
experiments as well and then pledge to
the experiment
the distributed computing project for
Atlas takes two concepts workflow
management and data management merges
them together we basically schedule
computational tasks is really like a
huge batch farm across all those data
centers it interacts with the compute
and the data management is in charge of
all the experiment data and you can see
from the curve on the left-hand side
that we're roughly at we're approaching
400 petabyte of experiment data there
now this includes user output data two
detector rate everything but we also
have a very large operations and support
team and without these people nothing
would work so they do the data bases to
monitoring the analytics for the
experiments okay um now I would like to
quickly touch the data management system
because that's where I'm primarily
involved in when we think data
management for science this is really
completely different to a business use
case because the science workflows as
Matt already explained the they are a
bit complicated so what we try to do is
we we try to have this global name space
that we can federate across all the
different storage systems that the
countries provide we need to control and
account the data and users we need to
have some policies and rules on the data
we have to transfer data between the
data centers we have to make sure that
when the jobs access to data that it's
available we can do popularity based
things replication caching all those
kinds of things and then we also have to
interact with all the other systems that
actually need the data so it's the
system is called Ruscio and this is the
one that we're actually integrated with
the Google cloud platform so I think in
the interest of time I will just skip to
the next slide because that's actually
where it gets interesting
when we do orchestrated storage to
storage transfers so basically copying a
couple of petabytes from France to the
nighted states we have to hop through
many different research networks and as
you can see we do roughly 5 petabytes of
transfers per week all of the different
types of activities but when the data is
there the actual jobs need to do
something with them so the job IO
we get per week is much much higher than
the actual orchestrated activities so
the other one we can schedule we have a
list of data that we want to transfer we
know roughly a month in advance which
data we actually want to move but when
we have users accessing it this is
completely chaotic and as Matt showed
you push a button and suddenly you try
to work through a petabytes sample of
data and we have to make sure that this
is properly orchestrated not only
worldwide but also at the low level with
the storage systems ok so that looks
actually quite well and we work so what
is the problem at the problem you can
see here on this plot on the left hand
side that is the prediction of the
amount of data that we will need and
you'll see there's a very big jump in
2025 this is when we will get the high
luminosity upgrade to the Large Hadron
Collider so from roughly one exabyte of
data and we will jump up to a four and
more exabytes of data and already now at
400 petabytes we are having quite a bit
of trouble getting the job io working so
this data deluge this is not not only a
problem for for the LHC we see this
across many fields of science and the
main problem there is that of course
storage continues to be the major cost
factor the science output rate exceeds
the infrastructure growth rate at any
possible rate I mean you can't leverage
so much Texas step that you build many
more science centers so this we call
this tactical resources it's like we
want to use these excess resources that
are available in the world and so Atlas
in Google joint forces
to start the data ocean R&D project
there's this data Lake concept that's
very much used in business so we try to
give it a funny spin and just call it
the data ocean just to make it bigger
there's absolutely no meaning behind
this right so what we try to do is we
wanted to make it easy for the science
users in the experiment to benefit from
what Google Cloud can provide us but on
the other hand we also wanted to learn
from Google how they do their things so
we wanted to evaluate adopt and benefit
from the novel technologies that are
available on the market so at the
supercomputing conference last year in
Denver we had our first meeting and we
started out with a large sheet of paper
and started to draw a potential
scenarios what we could do and we ended
up with our first white paper on this
so the first use cases that we wanted
wanted to do is to ensure user analysis
imagine on the WCG your job runs it
produces output it writes it somewhere
in in the world but for example it ends
up in a data center in a remote country
with not-so-good network and the only
administrator there is a PhD student on
5% time data center goes down you have
to wait three days to get your job
output data that is clearly not what you
want so with Google cloud platform we
would be able to get a hundred percent
output availability by making an
additional copy on the cloud also we
should be able to overflow the CPU to
cloud compute then the other thing that
we wanted to test is the data placement
replication and popularity I think we
really want to dynamically expand the
storage capacity use the additional
network that Google provides us between
our
national research networks for example
we can inject data in our data centers
in Amsterdam and have it use the Google
Network to move it to the US without
having to rely on our own research
networks and then of course within the
Google Network try to replicate it even
more and the third topic that we would
like to test is to get the internal data
formats that we use for the job i/o
itself what we use is a if you know hdf5
it's it's a data format using trees we
use the root system for this so what we
want we want to rip it apart into its
constituents and try to figure out what
would happen if we don't use files so
eventually we would end up with a couple
trillion events then that we need to
process so we're clearly not there it so
we wanted to do some cloud based
marshalling of events from this ok so
how do we get data into Google Cloud
storage this is the necessary first step
but the LHC is running so we can just
shut it down and and do this so we had
to integrate this transparently and on
the fly because down times while the LHC
is running a very very costly so what we
try to do is to make GCS just another
data center within the WCG so this means
within all the existing heterogeneous
data centers that we have we had to make
sure it supports all the data policies
it supports the user data access with
the authorization and authentication
it must support the existing protocols
that we use and also the existing tool
chain that we have so this was quite a
bit of development effort so we started
with s free because we had full stack
support from top tube to the bottom and
you can see in the center there's the
ratio data management system that
connects the WL cg sites and the the
Google Cloud storage but then we quickly
figured out that if we continue to use
as free as our primary data access
protocol that we're running into some
serious problems because the
it's rate limited on the storage sites
and the really what's the major problem
is that the key distribution is
problematic so imagine we have our
credentials to access Google cluster and
we start to hand it out to our users and
somebody decides to just run through a
couple of petabytes of data we would
rack up a bill that that we could never
fund so what we decided to do is we say
okay we don't use the compatibility
layer with as free we move to a Google
cloud platform native client signed URLs
and with that we have complete control
over the integration so these first
movements we did they were quite
manually slow and tedious to to s3 but
with the scienter rel support this
basically allowed us to use the Google
cloud platform like any other web dev
storage which was really cool and then
we use this to do user analysis input to
the European West one and the u.s. East
one storage areas in gzp and what
happened was that we maxed out the
intermediate throughput and started to
overload the storage from the WCG
because we couldn't even inject it fast
enough into into Google storage so we
were quite happy with that when you have
your data in you want to compute and we
have a system built in collaboration
with the University of Texas Arlington
and Brookhaven National Laboratory
it's called panda and it has a component
called the harvester so what the
harvester does is it basically is a
real-time view on the capabilities of
your cloud and it tells you how much
usage you have from from the experiment
point of view not from the
infrastructure point of view and what is
the integration with the cloud costs
that we actually have so we continuously
fire up virtual machines with the actual
computational pilots in them we can pull
the VM States we can shut them down when
necessary and
with this habit the compute engine
completely integrated into our batch
workflow and at the bottom the the
Ruscio system takes care of moving the
data from the WL see chief systems
storage systems into the google cloud
storage through the orchestrated
transfers so we started with Atlas
simulation jobs when I set at the
beginning that we get a lot of data out
of the detector we even get more data
from our simulation I think to split
this something 30% to 70% so 70% is just
pure simulated data now what we need to
do is we need to run these simulations
on the Google compute engine clusters
and read the i/o from the CERN storage
that was the first step we wanted to
show that we can run the compute on
Google but accessing the data at CERN
and then we moved on to also use the i/o
from Google compute in the meantime we
decided that we could try to profit from
the preemptable virtual machines and you
can see on the left hand side of the
plot we use the normal VMs that are
available on GCE and then we switch to
printable VM so this basically means
that the infrastructure can take out the
VM and underneath you however if you if
you do this you gain a lot of dollars
per event so this was a very positive
experience there so the Atlas analysis
also works we proved the simulation case
was just a first step we can use GCE
with i/o from CERN with i/o from GCS and
it's completely and fully automated so
the physicists themselves don't even
know that their jobs are running on
Google or that the data is used from
Google so what is the take home message
the science workflows and the software
that we use a complex and complicated to
a point where we can't just
go ahead and change things because we
need to have repeatable experiments so
if we decide to make an addition like
enabling support for a commercial cloud
provider we have to make sure that this
is done in a very very conservative way
so all these workflows have to
transparently integrate these providers
but then we come to the next step
because the scientists themselves are
starting to get cautious to scientists
the data is the most precious resource
they literally don't care about the
infrastructure and where it runs but if
you tell them we're taking all your data
that is basically your livelihood and
we're putting it on a commercial company
and it's not on publicly funded in
science infrastructure yet they start to
get very very cautious so what we are
trying to do here is we are trying to
win the scientists were basically trying
to win ourselves over by providing
ourselves tools to use the commercial
platforms in a way that makes sense to
us so we can allow our existing science
software to run transparently against a
commercial provider while at the same
time keeping complete control of the
data so for us really the important part
was to have a data management system to
be able to do that so imagine you're a
your science community you're not on the
scale of Atlas you're maybe 10 people 5
to 10 people and you decide ok I have
access to my university storage cluster
but I would really like to get some
capability from Google storage
completely integrated into my workflow
you can use our Ruscio system to do this
you can use the Panda and Harvester
system to do this so we really give you
the possibility here to integrate your
existing on-premise
capabilities with the commercial cloud
providers and give you as a science
customer full control over all your
collaborations data so Atlas and Google
are committed to a long-term
collaboration this is not a one-time
thing so we're really looking forward to
scaling out even more we have many more
experiments that are deploying the same
tools and we are giving them essentially
the capability for free
to hook into the commercial cloud
providers and use it as part of their
science workflows and with that I'm at
the end thank you
[Applause]
you
[Music]